an update here at noon police in
california say tiger woods is
lucky to be alive after his rollover
crash south of los angeles yesterday
morning
here's chris martinez with an update
[Applause]
tiger woods is recovering in a los
angeles county hospital from serious leg
injuries
after his suv rolled over down an
embankment
a statement posted to the golfer's
twitter page says doctors put a rod in
his right tibia
and used screws and pins to stabilize
his ankle
and foot i don't know all of the details
but we're talking
at least six months of recovery here
you know to be able to get to some
semblance of walking to playing a sport
to playing golf
authorities say woods was driving in a
hilly area of a los angeles suburb when
his borrowed suv
crashed into a raised median took out a
sign crossed over the southbound lanes
and traveled several hundred feet
the vehicle rolled multiple times before
landing on its side in the brush
police and residents say that stretch of
road is a trouble spot
known for speeding and accidents we
spend a lot of money on breaks
per year because you really need to ride
them as you're going down this grade
woods is 45 years old and was already
recovering from his fifth back surgery
he was hoping to return to the masters
in april but is now facing even bigger
challenges
life first hey golf is second and then
competitive golf
is possibly a long way down the line all
we can do is pray for him and hope that
he finds a way to rebuild himself even
in the twilight of his career and after
more than a decade of injuries and
personal struggles
woods remained one of the biggest draws
on the pga tour
chris martinez cbs news torrance
california
well tiger's accident comes as a new
study is released on crash tests and
safety
the insurance institute for highway
safety performs a number of crash tests
to determine if a car is safe
this year a record 90 new vehicles
earned a top safety pick that is up from
64 last year
the institute president david harkey
says more vehicles made the grade
because of auto braking systems
and better headlights casting more light
down the road for the driver
and eliminating that glare for the
oncoming drivers
so something to note here the institute
has not yet tested the genesis gv80
that's the car
tiger was in yesterday during that crash
the luxury suv does have modern safety
features including multiple airbags
two other genesis cars were tested and
earned top awards
investigators say the interior was more
or less intact in tiger's crash which
likely saved his life that was the
aftermath it did not look good